hey 42 here Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart
wrote his first symphony at the age of 8
at the age of 8 most children are busy
contemplating what dirt tastes like but
Mozart was a genius in the truest sense
of the word but he was also a chronic
procrastinator in october 1787 Mozart's
newest and highly anticipated two-part
opera was due to premiere at prague
national theater but the night before
the premiere Mozart went out drinking
with his friends he told his friends
that he had not yet written a single
musical note of his latest opera it was
true the Opera didn't even exist yet
because Mozart had put it off until
literally the night before yet that
night over just three hours mozart
finally put quill to paper and scribbled
down the entire musical notation for his
brand-new opera whilst his wife kept him
awake by reading folk tales to him such
as Cinderella during the performance the
next day the ink was still wet on the
musical notation and the orchestra had
not even rehearsed once yet all went
smoothly and Mozart's opera called Don
Giovanni was very well received by the
entire audience so with it my advice to
you is to avoid starting that humongous
and very essential project until the
night before No obviously that is
terrible advice because I'm willing to
bet that you're not quite the genius
that Mozart was Martin Luther King also
wrote his I have a dream speech at the
very last minute it is also widely
rumoured that Abraham Lincoln quickly
scribbled out his famous Gettysburg
Address in just a few minutes during the
train journey to Gettysburg but again
don't fool yourself into thinking that
you could do the exact same thing with
your university thesis the slow claws of
procrastination will eventually sink
into was all the bigger the task ahead
of us the more likely we are to instead
tune into MTV to find out what some
morally and socially challenged teenager
is doing for their sickly sweet 16th
because at the end of the day we can
always do it tomorrow and inevitably we
will tell ourselves the exact same lie
the following day
procrastination is so prevalent amongst
us all other Germans have even written a
short poem about it
Morgan Morgan or Nita zackin al awwalin
Lita tomorrow tomorrow not today all the
lazy people say procrastination is even
entered medical literature some people
actually plan to procrastinate telling
themselves that they don't want to and
actually won't start a project until
just before the deadline the logic is
that when one is under a supreme amount
of stress they are more likely to put a
greater amount of effort into the task
the medical world has named this student
syndrome and no that's not another one
of my crappy jokes
it really has got that name
procrastination is always seen as a bad
thing
an ugly quality in a person that should
be eradicated but what if we look at it
from a different perspective some
psychologists believe that
procrastination can be a good thing and
a powerful tool and we should all be
utilizing I bet you're thinking wow I
should be actively doing absolutely
nothing more often do tell me more
Internet man well sort of it's only in
very recent times that procrastination
has been viewed by society as a negative
quality in a person for most of history
it has been quite steep opposite the
ancient Greeks and Romans had great
respect for the art of procrastination
after all rome wasn't built in a day
they spent the first thousand years
figuring out the most sociable way to
take a crap the Romans in Greeks
believed strongly in the power of doing
Bouguereau
for many hours at a time instead of
putting up that shelf that has been
sitting there for a month or writing
their memoirs they would quite happily
choose to sit around in their togas all
day counting reduces snakes for they
believed that it was only when we do
absolute
nothing that up greatest ideas and
epiphanies can manifest in our minds
high-ranking ancient Greeks and Romans
would go as far as only doing something
when and if they absolutely had to they
had the most severe student syndrome it
is often forced that professional tennis
players are at the very top of their
game because they are so fast but in
actuality the complete opposite is true
the very best tennis players are the
very best because they are the slowest
of all players they procrastinate more
than other players let me explain when a
tennis ball is served in your direction
you have less than 500 milliseconds to
gauge its velocity and trajectory
position yourself correctly and ensure
you deliver the perfect stroke to return
it in the optimum way an amateur player
will try to play as fast as possible
they will hastily rush to wherever the
ball is heading they will swing in a
general direction whatever feels right
in just a split second whereas a
professional will spend every one of
those 500 milliseconds setting up the
perfect return play their stroke has
been perfected to such a level that they
are able to feel more vital milliseconds
to think about how the ball was served
and the current position and gait of
their opponent nothing is rushed their
response has been perfectly measured in
a slow calm fashion and thus their
return play will be infinitely better
than that of any amateur sometimes by
slowing down you can achieve greatness
for some people procrastinating is the
only way that they can actually get
anything done at all and can in some
situations produce higher quality and
greater quantities of work let's say you
have a deadline looming such as
finishing your final college assignment
and you should have started about three
months ago but to the last it's the
night before
you're supposed to hand it in tomorrow
yes you've written the ground sum of two
words title here in this extreme
situation which by the way studies have
shown us an astonishing 95 percent of
students actually do on a regular basis
something supernatural happens in your
brain panic starts to set in as it
suddenly dawns on you that if you don't
write 10,000 words tonight you'll walk
away from two years of study without a
qualification at all and so a flood of
adrenaline is released at your brain
more precisely your body releases a huge
amount of epinephrine epinephrine is
like cocaine on cocaine studies have
proved that when taking stimulant drugs
such as cocaine and to a lesser extent
caffeine your productivity skyrockets
you are able to achieve many times the
quantity of work in any given time
period and your ability to soak up and
learn new information is also greatly
enhanced but epinephrine or adrenaline
is a far more powerful drug than even
cocaine under its influence you can
achieve things that you never thought
possible
such as writing at ten thousand word
essay in one evening many people myself
included rely on this adrenaline release
we experience when we are under severe
pressure and facing a fast approaching
deadline to complete huge amounts of
work that we would otherwise never even
begin so procrastination can sometimes
with an asterisk be a useful tool but
what causes it why do you sit up it ii
am googling your dog's name instead of
working there's a secret about
procrastination that not many people
know procrastination it's not caused by
laziness or a lack of motivation when
you decide to watch a video review of a
toaster that you don't or will never own
instead of working it's not because you
are inherently lazy
your peers in truth research has shown
that most people procrastinate because
they are stressed think about the last
time you procrastinated did you have a
huge dark cloud of stress hanging over
you and maybe you had a deadline fast
approaching and you hadn't even started
the work maybe you had to do your
finances and you know that just by
looking at the poor state of your
finances it was going to cause you some
significant stress so what did you do
instead you did something completely
different you play video games you ate
you watched useless videos like this one
you procrastinated but what you were
actually doing is relieving the stress
surrounding that task that you are
supposed to be doing psychologists
believe that procrastination is no
different than smoking a cigarette or
drinking alcohol it's just a mechanism
to relieve the stresses in your life the
problem with this mechanism is that in a
cruel and ironic way it steals the
precious time that you so vitally need
to solve the problem that is causing you
distress in the first place but crust a
nation may be useful from time to time
getting that adrenaline flowing at the
very last moment so you can achieve
superhuman levels of productivity but
chronic procrastination can really
affect the path that your life will take
you see there are two kinds of tasks in
your life the deadline tasks and
self-imposed tasks deadline tasks are
when others have set a strict deadline
whether it be your boss or an
educational institute you may
procrastinate instead of finishing such
a task for many many weeks but when it
comes to the final hours most people
will use that kick of adrenaline and
overwhelming panic to finish all the
work and do a fairly okay job of it in
the end but things are completely
different when you set yourself a task
say you have a great idea for a business
that you'd like to start on but the time
and effort required to get it up and
running is monumental so most likely
you'll just never do it you
procrastinate at
you say you'll join the gym and finally
get into peak physical shape but of
course you never do why because you have
no deadline to do these things nobody's
going to reprimand you or punish you if
you don't start up that business within
the next six months or attends the gym
everyday life will just go on as it
always has and you will forever tell
yourself that you will start working on
it next week this is called chronic
procrastination and it's not a good
thing because you could potentially be
denying yourself a life-changing
opportunity that hampster bathing suit
company won't start itself you know many
of us suffer from chronic
procrastination it's hardwired into our
biology we are programmed to avoid
dangerous and potentially risky
situations
anything that strays out of the normal
urban flow of our everyday lives such as
starting a new business or taking up a
new hobby could potentially be risky
that risk may come in the form of
financial social or even health so our
biology is pre-programmed to just avoid
that risk by never acting upon it by
procrastinating indefinitely
but what if I told you that there are
some really simple cheats you can use to
say goodbye to chronic procrastination
forever and start actually achieving
things for once the world's best
psychologists have been working on ways
we can easily overcome procrastination
for years and these are the secret
techniques that they have come up with
and without trying to sound too much
like an infomercial here they have been
clinically proven to work I've tried to
myself and they really do but first it
sponsor time and what better way to kick
your procrastination habit and put your
mind to something great than by joining
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes in design business technology
and so much more a premium membership
gives you truly unlimited access to
high-quality classes on most no topics
so you can improve your skills and on
lock new opportunities maybe you can
finally start that business you've been
dreaming of all these years orb learn a
skill that you never thought you'll be
able to such as cooking or programming
if like me you've always been interested
in entrepreneurship and starting your
dream business you should 100% check out
the skill share course entrepreneurship
hustle from business plan to real-world
success it's an essential introduction
to creating a strong brand that people
will remember and talk about it's a
must-watch skill share is also more
affordable than most learning platforms
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month that's just a couple of
coffees and since skill share have
kindly sponsored this video the first
500 people to use the promo link in the
description will get their first two
months completely free so for goodness
sake stop procrastinating click on the
link and start learning something
amazing today so what are these
techniques you can use to finally start
the work that you really should have
started about two weeks ago the first
technique is to simply break down that
huge task into tiny really specific
tasks and then set a time limit to each
of these micro tasks your first micro
tasks can be write a list of micro tasks
whatever you do just don't procrastinate
on that otherwise you'll enter some
weird paradox and go into another
dimension or something even though this
technique doesn't actually reduce your
overall workload psychologically it
feels so much more achievable and in
every single way easier to accomplish a
series of very small tasks than one huge
task it's similar to when I want to eat
a very large pizza just take it one
slice at a time every time you finish
one of these micro tasks your brain will
release a shot of dopamine and you'll
feel accomplished thus maintaining your
morale and vastly increasing the
likelihood that you'll move on to the
next task instead of giving up
altogether this next trick sounds
blatantly stupid but it's ridiculously
powerful simply start the war
just force yourself to begin but here's
the trick
tell yourself you're only going to work
for five minutes and then you can
continue whatever useless
procrastination you were in the middle
of five minutes ago just five minutes
that's all in every study where this
technique was attempted with test
participants almost every person
voluntarily continued working well past
five minutes and many simply continued
working on the task for several hours
even though they had told themselves
that five minutes was all they had to do
psychologically once you begin working
on a task even if it's really difficult
and natural urge to want to keep at it
kicks in and it actually becomes harder
to stop than to carry on 99% of the
difficulty of overcoming procrastination
is actually starting the work
hence the old blank page writer's block
dilemma but because the hardest part is
making a start you may have to force
yourself to do so in Homer's Odyssey it
tells of a fable involving the Greek
King Ulysses Ulysses and his crew were
aboard a ship whilst passing an island
full of sirens
you know those many islands full of
naked devil women that you see
absolutely everywhere the sirens were
singing out in angelic voices and
calling out Ulysses to join them on
their sexy rocky outcrop Ulysses knew
that he could not resist the temptation
of the sirens so he ordered his crew to
forcibly tie him to a mast on the ship
and block his ears until the seductive
sirens were long outta sight so what's
the lesson here
when you are faced with a huge amount of
work and the blank page or just an
island full of naked women you must be
really forceful with yourself and just
make a damp start thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
support the channel to make sure I can
continue to make them in the future then
consider clicking the join button below
to become a part of the private 42
community here on YouTube where you'll
get early access to all my new videos
and show
private vlogs by myself I'd also like to
thank Skillshare once again for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
use the promo link below before it's too
late to join Skillshare today because
trust me you won't regret it